thank you first of all I'm really
tickled and honored to be here to be
able to help celebrate Jones retirement
I guess I'll just say a couple of things
about our interactions over career I
think that probably we cross paths the
least of all of the let's say the
speaker's here but I've known of John's
work from you know the I'm gonna say the
seventies nineteen eighty and at one
point I was just fascinated with the
work on sort of coupling arguments and
everything and I have to say I spent so
much time trying to understand it so
that I could sort of make use of it and
at some point I finally was able to sort
of write some papers but I really think
of them all as sort of copies of work
that you had done the other thing was
one semester after you came out with
your queuing networks textbook I decided
to use it and I was struck by both the
breadth that it was covering analysis
control modeling and also at the same
time how you sort of think way beyond
people like myself and so you see that
step and when I see what you sort of
have is the next step I then found for
the sake of the students I had to spend
hours sometimes trying to fill in
step and in fact you know I think most
any other person who had attempted to
write that textbook would have written
one that would have been seven hundred
and fifty to a thousand pages instead of
the whatever was three hundred and fifty
four hundred pages
okay in any case I'm really sort of glad
to be here I guess I'm gonna be talking
about sort of a different topic than
what we've seen the other thing is that
there you're gonna find very little math
in this particular talk but I'm hoping
that it'll raise some consciousness in
terms of what might be some interesting
problems to be looking at we're gonna
start off I don't know how many here
know any quantum theory so I'm gonna
give you sort of quantum theory 101 then
we'll talk about entanglement networks
which is what this talk is all about and
then I'd like to talk about sort of
research issues I'm going to use an
example of a application that I worked
on with some of my collaborators to sort
of try to illustrate some of that and
then summarize okay so elementary
quantum 101 okay well we're familiar
with sort of the digital technology you
have a bit that has only two values zero
and one there are lots of ways that you
can represent it the canonical example
of course is a light bulb off on but it
could be low or high voltage in a
circuit but what we're interested in our
quantum bits and it's termed a qubit and
it basically corresponds to a two-state
quantum mechanical system and and the
canonical example is sort of like photon
polarization where you can have
polarization and sort of like horizontal
plane well and you could have it in the
vertical plane and these are two states
then are sort of represented as using
bracket notation like this but as Darius
said it's basically glorified linear
algebra in term
of sort of what goes on here okay but
the thing is that you can have the
polarization any combination of the two
okay and so you can have sort of a super
vicious superposition of states if you
think of it what I showed you in the
previous slide is really sort of a basis
for what you can sort of build and so we
can have a state fee which is
essentially a combination of these two
set of basis vectors and these
coefficients in front the important
thing is that when you square them and
some of them they equal one okay and
there are a number of sort of like
important superposition States I've just
sort of listed a couple here and they're
really just sort of linear combinations
of the two basis vectors now because
when I said it you have an uncountable
number of states okay and so you can
have let's say a photon that's in a
particular state and you send it through
sort of a filter and what will happen is
that you'll get an outcome being one of
those two basis States you'll either get
X or you'll get Y okay you don't get
both and it turns out that it's
completely random if you repeat this
experiment many many times what you'll
find is that the probability or the
fraction of times that you let's say get
an X out is given by the square of the
coefficient that was in front and
likewise Y that it's a beta squared and
so that's a sort of physical
interpretation of alpha and beta well I
talked about this with one qubit but you
can have multiple qubits and so with two
qubits represented like this we have
sort of four basis States in that case
and
so they're super position of two cubits
then would just be written as this
combination and I'll just mention again
there are a number of superposition
states that are sort of important and
useful in quantum one of them is called
the Bell state and it corresponds to
this it's a superposition of the 0 0 and
the 1 1 and this of course is just to
make sure that everything is normalized
properly ok so let's look at this it
turns out that this is really a very
useful superposition suppose that what
you do
ok you've got these two qubits and the
first thing you do is you measure the
first one the way that I mentioned
passing it ELISA through a filter and
it's going to yield either a 0 or 1 ok
now it turns out if you get a 1 and then
you go to measure the second qubit
you're always going to get a 1 and
likewise if you had measured the 0 then
measuring the second qubit Geils r0 and
that turns out to be incredibly powerful
I should mention that there are other
kinds of measurement correlations that
you can sort of play around with in
quantum but the important thing is that
this sort of entanglement between these
two qubits is sort of the basis of
quantum computing a quantum key
distribution quantum sensing and and so
on and so a lot of what's needed is to
have ways of sort of generating and
propagating these entanglements as sort
of like a primitive to be used for these
other applications ok so suppose that
the way that I said it described it it's
sort of easy to think of it yet you're
in the lab you have the two qubits you
measure one the other one comes out to
be the same but what you for it to be
useful you'd like to be able
have these qubits separate them out to
let's say two completely different
parties okay so you might have a
superposition state and Alice and what
Alice would like to do is to propagate
the second qubit to Bob and so it could
be over an optical fiber it's got some
sort of transmittivity let's say the
distance is L and what's going to happen
is that if alice is going to send Photon
they sort of like corresponding to that
it could get lost get lost at some point
it makes it and now bob has that's
second qubit and it's been shown that
the rate at which you can sort of do
this at is for sort of small values of
transmittivity it's it's essentially
linear in the transmittivity okay and
the transmittivity turns out to be an
exponentially decaying function of the
length or the distance between the two
and so that what that has resulted in is
that you can sort of do this let's say
directly between Alice and Bob for
distances that might be on the order of
tens of kilometers maybe in space it
would be much much farther but you can't
do this and sort of like a national or
intercontinental level and so what that
suggests is what we would like then is
some kind of a quantum network that
would allow us to be able to do that
where we have Alice we have Bob there's
some paths to Bob and that they would
somehow be able to generate an
end-to-end entanglement between them and
if we could do that then that would
essentially allow lots of different
applications of secure communications as
was alluded to by dariya a distributed
computing that's becoming sort of really
very much of interest because companies
are now being able to build small
quantum computers but if they really
wanted to have many many qubits
available to them at this point and
probably for many years they'd have to
be able to connect lots of them and
there of course are undoubtedly lots of
applications yet to be done so in order
to do that you need to have sort of
repeaters to be able to generate these
end-to-end entanglements and so I want
to sort of describe the process quickly
at a high level of how an entanglement
would be created the first thing you
would do these are the repeaters right
here there might be think of it as let's
say a bunch of channels between each of
them they're referred to as modes there
could be different frequencies in the
optical domain that it could be a time
division kind of thing and the first
thing that is attempted is to create
entanglements just between neighboring
repeaters okay and let's say the Peanuts
the probability that it will succeed
then all you need is for one of these to
succeed let's say this one here and
that's going to be with probability P
given by this expression when you have M
modes oh the end here that is think of
the distance its measured in terms of
the number of Link's number of repeaters
okay and then once that's done that can
all be done at the same time you then
splice these links together using what
are called Bell state measurements okay
and there's a probability that that will
success which I'll call Q and so that
would be attempted let's say here here
here and if they succeed then you'll
have an end-to-end entanglement between
Alice and Bob and what I'm going to do
really for the rest of the talk is I'm
going to just sort of think of it as
looking like this as if there's really
only one mode between the repeaters some
probability P of successfully getting a
link entanglement Q of splicing okay
and so now you can think of a quantum
entanglement network then with the lots
of these connected together just as you
sort of would see for a classical
network and this would now allow you
could you know connect multiple users
and so they could all be these different
pairs of users trying to generate Indian
entanglements or you could think of it
that you have multiple paths per user
pair in this so you could try to sort of
take advantage of of let's say the path
diversity that you might have and so
I'll be talking about that first just a
slide of sort of challenges in terms of
performance and control this area is
really completely in its infancy and so
the questions just abound given pairs of
users what's the capacity region for
this what's the right way to sort of
allocate resources among these various
user pairs should you do stateless or
stateful control and I'll talk a little
bit about that in context of as an
example should you do like set up static
routes maybe using some sort of
something like an internet protocol or
should you be opportunistic as you can
do in wireless suppose that you have a
particular sort of set of mechanisms you
know how do you go about modeling
latency if because of course it's going
to take some time it's there time before
and then then entanglement is created
this random okay so what I'd like to do
is I'm going to turn to a piece of work
that I did with colleague
that I had listed in in the first slide
sort of looking a little bit at state
information to path diversity and I
should mention that we sort of undertook
this as physicists would using sort of
simulation numerical simulation and so
to me one of the things I hope you get
out of this is that there's really a lot
of room for theoretical development a
simple 2d grid network we're gonna
assume there's just one mode per link
just one memory per repeater per link so
it looks like that diagram I had at the
bottom of the slide earlier and let's
start off there's just one pair of nodes
that want to to generate entanglement ok
so here's here's the picture of our grid
network with I don't know let's say
Alice is here Bob is here there's some
probability P that you can generate an
entanglement across a link and if we
sort of follow the recipe that I I
described to you before in the first
phase you try to create as many link
entanglements as possible and maybe this
is the result of that first phase okay
and then in the second phase you decide
which pairs of links to try to splice
together notice here there's no question
about what to do but you have to decide
let's say in this case which pair and
and so on and so here what I've done is
sort of done a particular one and I
think what we find is that the result is
that you actually have two paths between
Alice and Bob and so in this particular
operation they are able to generate two
bits of entanglement I didn't mention
a bit of entanglement is oft is referred
to as an E bit in the quantum world okay
so now what we're interested is what
what's the rate that which Alice and Bob
can generate these entanglements yes so
I'm not quite sure what your question is
so let's say this node may decide to try
to splice this together the this node
splice this together likewise this it's
all done simultaneously and at the end
if it's successful then the let's say
the there's an entanglement let's say
between Alice and Bob okay so what we're
interest is you know what's the rate at
which these entanglements can be
generated and so here is an attempt to
sort of get an idea but let's say where
we have sort of an offline algorithm and
so we looked at a greedy shortest path
algorithm okay this is not optimal the
first thing you do is if once you've
generated these two phases and excuse me
once you generate the first phase then
you see what the shortest path is that
you could generate by doing these
splices and then after you do that
what's the next one you could do and the
next one okay and so just going to refer
to that as greedy and it requires global
information and let's say that this is
what the the entanglement rate
and so here I'm sort of showing what the
rate looks like is a function of the
distance in the x-axis and then the
y-axis between Alice and Bob okay
for a link success probability 0.55 in
perfect Bell State measurement perfect
splices and then this is what you get if
the link success probability is 0.45
I have a question anybody know so here
it's pretty constant it doesn't depend
on the distance but here there's clearly
a decay does somebody want to tell me
what the reason is okay right right it
turns out that's just I was thinking of
what Dario was saying about percolation
is here we're above the percolation
threshold for a 2d grid when we do bond
percolation and here we're just below
that's what's going on okay so now
suppose so that was an offline algorithm
that uses perfect noise let's see if we
can generate an upper bound of what's
possible okay if it turns out that the
splices can be done successfully
these bail state measurements are
perfect then you can just run a max flow
algorithm and you can find the the
achievable right with global information
unfortunately if there's some
probability that one of these splices
will fail there is at least we don't
know of an algorithm for obtaining and
so we just have a very simple upper
bound that just takes four times the
rate that you get from that greedy
algorithm I mentioned in the previous
slide and so here is the upper bound or
let's say link success probability 0.6
perfect splices here is what you get
running that greedy algorithm that I
mentioned in the previous slide and then
here's what you get running the greedy
algorithm where 10% of the time you fail
to connect two links and this is the
upper bound that you obtain and I guess
something I didn't mention what we're
doing is looking at the log of the rate
okay so so the gap the difference
between this is essentially okay now
let's see what we could do just using
local state information okay one of the
problems is okay so you can do these
these link entanglements all in parallel
you can do these splices or Bell State
measurements all in parallel but in
order to be able to use global
information you'd have to propagate the
information having to do with the
success of the link experiments
everywhere before you could do the
second phase and clearly that's not
something that that one can can do so
what we're going to do is we're going to
assume that each node each repeater
knows its Euclidean distance from Alice
and from Bob okay so that's the I guess
the global information that it will make
use of and so here from the perspective
of you it knows what the distances are
for its four neighbors okay so it runs
the first phase and if this is the only
link that's exceeded there's nothing
that you has to do if two links created
an entanglement well that's easy there's
only one choice
if there are three now the greedy or the
algorithm what we're going to use is
just that you're going to connect a to
that sort of create potentially the
shortest path between Alice and Bob okay
and so when you look at let's say the
distance from Alice a distance from Bob
for this node and likewise for this and
for this when you sum them up you
realize this potentially this will
result in the shortest path and if all
four succeed then you do the same thing
you first of all find the potentially of
the shortest path and then after that
you go ahead and just splice the other
two together okay and so I'm gonna refer
to the rate that you get as our loke and
here I'm showing you the the rate for
the greedy algorithm here's what you get
if you use this local rule and then what
we're going to compare against is the
rate that you would get if you had
decided to just allocate single static
paths between Alice and Bob okay let's
say end so this is of the same distance
in which case you have no diversity here
and that's the this curve this surface
right here and you notice that both of
them have an exponential decay but the
decay is much faster for the the linear
and so you're getting benefit from sort
of allowing this diversity okay I'm
gonna just say a little bit about multi
flow routing and again it's more just
sort of raised questions let's take a
setting where we have to Alice's to
Bob's and Alice both cases is above Bob
okay
now you could do the following you could
just say well I'll give the entire set
of resources to altitude the first pair
and then the next time slot to the
second pair or some other kind of
multiplexing and if you do that you
would get this as the the rate region
for that algorithm or another
possibility is what you might do is just
divide the resources that each pair have
its own set of resources and they could
proceed in parallel and if you do that
you get a little bit of an increase in
the rate region and then the third is
you you do as I said before but whenever
there are let's say operations are going
to result in a failure let's say for
Alice 1 and Bob 1 you allow those
resources to be used by Alice the second
pair and what's interesting in that case
is you actually can get a huge
improvement in the rate region by doing
that here's another configuration again
just the sort of give you a sense of
issues now here they're clearly sort of
like at odds with each other they have
to sort of use go through the same part
of the network in order to be able to
communicate with them and so if they do
time division multiplexing that's this
blue curve right here if they sort of
split the resources let's say by let's
say this hourglass belonging to pair 1
and this hourglass the pair 2 or the
bowtie and you have you know some sort
of parameter that decides how to do it
then interestingly enough you can get
this as the rate region and then finally
if you allow resources in the hourglass
abuse for Alice to and Bob to when they
can't help Alice 1 and Bob 1 you get
some additional and
right there okay so so Betts brings me
to the end I just want to sort of
mention open questions let's say here is
you know I've given you really a bunch
of heuristics and said there's a really
question of what what is the the rate
optimal protocol for this system
something that I glossed over we
everything was under the assumption
there's only one memory per link one
mode on each link and so you know once
you sort of allow for multiple modes and
multiple memories there may be ideas
that can come from queuing theory
perhaps that could be applied here
something else I didn't mention is these
qubits don't stay around forever they
have a sort of a finite time that
they'll exist at a decent quality and
then they just sort of fall apart and so
there's that's referred to as coherence
time and so that's something that sort
of adds another dimension there's this
notion of purification that when you do
an entanglement I've been sort of
talking about it as if it's perfect and
they the results can be a variable
quality and by sort of repeating the the
same operation over and over again you
can purify and increase the quality of
the entanglement that comes up and last
is I've talked about everything in terms
of it's an end to end pair of nodes that
want to create an entanglement and there
are other kinds of entanglements that
let's say include more than two qubits I
think of that the sort of starts to seem
like a multicast our group
communications and classical networking
okay so so the conclusions of quantum
repeater networks achieve much better
performance than linear chains even just
for a single pair of
users and even if you just use local
information and with multi flows it
looks like you should exploit spatial
information and just say that you know
the research here is really in its
infancy and that I think they're just
many exciting problems and what I'd like
to leave to you John this retirement
celebration is you need a new hobby
and if you do why don't you think of to
another research ok that's that's
interesting when I first started I was
really thinking wide area network I
think that probably the initial sweet
spot is think of it as a data center
with a lot of small quantum computers
that need to be connected and so it may
be that just sort of looking at the
equivalent of crossbar switches or I
don't know maybe it's a ring or whatnot
that that that's most likely to sort of
see the light of day the my
collaborators really an optical person
and so I was thinking of this is
photonic network but it doesn't have to
be there's also working microwave
that works as well let's say online okay
thanks
[Applause]